a lot of wild things happen in the 80s
set
fifth episode of wandevision so it's
understandable if you need an assist in
understanding it all
perplexing plot twists are par for the
course with this show
but somehow it's getting weirder here's
the ending of episode 5
explained following their fast-tracked
birth in episode 3
billy and tommy maximoff can't seem to
quit growing
with their parents backs turned the
twins go from mere infants to walking
talking kids
surprising their mom and dad alike
ah kids
can't control them no matter how hard
you try
[Music]
this isn't the only time billy and tommy
leap ahead
in the aging process either later wanda
begins to lecture them on the
responsibilities of taking care of a pet
concluding with the condition that they
can get a dog when they're 10 years old
adhering to their mother's demands the
twins once again
age years in the blink of an eye in one
of their final scenes of this
one division episode billy and tommy
attempt to process the loss of their dog
to make the pain easier to handle it's
implied that they're about to age up yet
again
but wanda stops them from doing so just
in time
strangely enough in the marvel comics
neither of the boys had the ability to
alter their age at will
meaning they've either gained a new
power for their live-action introduction
or something or someone is in control of
them
could it be agnes whom many have
theorized as the mcu's version of the
marvel comics witch agatha harkness
who mentored wanda in the comics and
knew about the nature of billy and
tommy's creation before their mother did
or could it be mephisto the demonic
character whose soul wanda inadvertently
took fragments from in order to have
children
given that vision can't pass on his dna
we don't know if
any of those tidbits that are canon in
the comics will be true
or even play some sort of role in
wandervision
but something tells us we'll find out
for sure in the coming weeks
the devil's in the details bev that's
not the only place he is
shortly after billy and tommy's
miraculous aging
we find out that the twins have taken a
lost puppy that they found outside
into their care bringing him in for a
bath he has no collar and no discernible
owner
so the family keeps him and names him
sparky following a worrisome incident
with a wall outlet
sparky the dog is actually a character
from marvel comics
a synthezoid created by vision as a gift
to his family following a different kind
of electrical mishap
in the comics his family doesn't include
wanda billy or tommy
but rather his synthazoid wife and
children virginia
vin and viv though given vision's
perplexed reaction to the canine and
juan division
it's pretty unlikely he had anything to
do with the origin story of this version
of sparky
at any rate such a detail isn't of major
importance given that sparky is
apparently already dead
thanks to sword's attempts to contact
wanda she opens the front door to
investigate
giving sparky the chance to escape and
raid agnes azalea bush
a plant that's toxic to dogs in the
comics sparky also meets a sad end
and eventually it's actually wanda
maximoff herself who brings sparky back
to the land of the living with an assist
from tony stark
however things go differently in juan
division despite billy and tommy's pleas
wanda refuses to bring their beloved pet
back from the grave
it seems that sparky's death serves as a
metaphor and a turning point
wanda's reality is quickly unfurling
she's losing control of the things
living inside it
and she knows she must confront the
universal truth that death is permanent
this applies not only to her husband
vision who died in infinity war
and whom she knows is dead but also to
her brother pietro who was killed in age
of ultron
we can't reverse death
no matter how sad it makes us it seems
as if wanda is beginning to realize that
she can't keep up this act forever
she's still going to try as the
subsequent events of the episode show
but it's certainly feeling like wanda
understands she's going to have to
accept
vision and pietro's deaths and move on
with her life
sooner rather than later too bad a pup
had to perish to get her there
after weeks of hinting the latest one
division episode takes vision's budding
paranoia over the nature of his reality
to an
all-time high it begins with agnes odd
conversation with wanda early in the
episode
where agnes asks wanda if she wants to
do another take of their conversation
as if she's aware they're in a
television show vision later questions
wanda about whether she thought the
exchange was odd
but wanda just brushes it off and tells
him not to worry
building off of this moment once at work
vision shows norm how to use a computer
and receives an email straight from
sword
he then wipes the monitor clean and
accesses his co-worker's mind
freeing him from wand to spell norm
immediately loses him
saying he needs to speak to his family
and that he doesn't know where he is
before vision places him back under west
view's trance
evidently this incident is the last
straw for vision as he confronts his
wife about it when he gets home
vision quickly loses his composure
begging wanda to tell him what's
happening what's outside of westview
and why he has no memories from before
their time there
wanda reassures him that she doesn't
entirely know what's going on
and that she's not in control of
everyone there attempting to put
vision's worries to rest
whether it's wanda holding everyone in
the town hostage or if it's someone else
remains to be seen
but wanda claims to not know how it all
began
i don't know how any of this started in
the first place
we do know however that nine days prior
to the events of this episode
wanda broke into a sword base to recover
vision's body
resurrecting him we learn would be a
violation of the sokovia accords
meant to reign in the avengers and would
also be against vision's living will
what happens when he learns the truth
perhaps the biggest shock of one
division's fifth episode comes in its
closing moments
just as vision begins really pushing
wanda to explain what's going on in
westview
their heated discussion is interrupted
by a doorbell chime
wanda opens the door and finds none
other than her deceased twin brother
pietro aka quicksilver waiting for her
however pietro doesn't look the same as
he did
when mcu fans first met him this time
around
he is portrayed by evan peters not age
of ultron actor
aaron taylor johnson according to darcy
wanda has
recast pietro which invites a slew of
questions that extend beyond wandevision
and into the entire mcu for those
unfamiliar with peter's connection to
quicksilver
he portrayed the lightning fast hero for
a time in 20th century studios x-men
franchise
he made his debut in x-men days of
future past in 2014
then appeared in 2016's x-men apocalypse
and finally in 2019's dark phoenix
as both a former avenger and a member of
the x-men quicksilver is so far
the only marvel comics character to be
played by two different actors and
appear
in both the marvel studios franchise
along with the 20th century fox
x-men franchise basically at the same
time given this marvel continuity pretty
much
ended when disney acquired 20th century
fox and the characters under his purview
many thought they might have seen the
last of this actor's take on pietro
but that's apparently not the case does
peter's introduction as pietro in one
division mean that the previously
disconnected x universe will soon be mcu
canon
alternatively is peters really playing
quicksilver in the mcu moving forward or
is this just some kind of elaborate ploy
beyond wanda's control
at any rate this marks the first time an
x-men franchise actor has stepped into
the mcu
as the character they've played before
so it's significant no matter what's
truly going on inside the series
narrative
all in all this one division episode
supplied viewers with plenty to think
about
as they wait for the newest installment
to hit disney plus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
wandavision are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one